we will now define the notion of a
random variable very loosely speaking a
random variable is a numerical quantity
that takes random values but what does
this mean we want to be a little more
precise and I'm going to introduce the
idea through an example suppose that our
sample space is a set of students
labelled according to their names or for
simplicity let's just label them as a B
C and D our probabilistic experiment is
to pick a student at random according to
some probability law and then record
their weight in kilograms so for example
suppose that the outcome of the
experiment was this particular student
and the weight of that student is 62 or
it could be that the outcome of the
experiment is this particular student
and that particular student has a weight
of 75 kilograms the weight of a
particular student is a number little W
but let us think of the abstract
concepts of weight something that we
will denote by capital W weight is an
object whose value is determined once
you tell me the outcome of the
experiment once you tell me which
student was picked in this sense weight
is really a function of the outcome of
the experiment so think of weight as an
abstract box that takes as input a
student and produces a number little W
which is the weight of that particular
student or more concretely think of
weight with a capital W as a procedure
that takes a student puts him or her on
a scale and reports the result in this
sense weight is an object of the same
kind as the square root function that's
setting inside your computer
the square root function is a function
it's a subroutine perhaps it is a piece
of code that takes as input a number
let's say the number nine and produces
another number in this case it would be
the number three which is the square
root of nine
notice here the distinction that we will
keep emphasizing over and over square
root of nine is a number it's the number
three the Box square root is a function
now let us go back to our probabilistic
experiments
note that the probabilistic experiment
such as the one in our example can have
several associated random variables for
example we could have another random
variable denoted by capital H which is
the height of a student recorded in
meters so if the outcome of the
experiment for example was student a
then this random variable would take a
value which is the height of that
student let's say it was point one point
seven or if the outcome of the
experiment was student C then we would
record the height of that student and
let us say that it turns out to be one
point eight once again height with a
capital H is an abstract object a
function whose value is determined once
you tell me the outcome of the
experiments now given some random
variables we can create new random
variables as functions of the original
random variables for example consider
the quantity defined as weight divided
by height squared this quantity is the
so-called body mass index and it is also
a function on the sample space why is it
a function on the sample space well
because once an outcome of the
experiment is determined suppose that
the outcome of the experiment was the
blue student then
these two numbers 62 and 1.7 are also
determined and using those numbers we
can carry out this calculation and find
the body mass index of that particular
student which in this case would be 21.5
or if it happened that this student was
selected then the body mass index would
turn out to be some other number in this
case it would be 23 so again we see that
the body mass index can be viewed as an
abstract concept defined by this formula
but once an outcome is determined then
the body mass index is also determined
and so the body mass index is really a
function of which particular outcome was
selected let us now abstract from the
previous discussion we have seen that
random variables are objects abstract
objects that associate a specific value
a particular number to any particular
outcome of a of a probabilistic
experiment so in that sense random
variables are functions from the sample
space to the real numbers there are
numerical functions but as numerical
functions they can either take discrete
values for example the integers or they
can take continuous values let's say on
the real line for example if your random
variable is the number of heads in 10
consecutive coin tosses this is a
discrete random variable that takes
values in the set from 0 to 10 if your
random variable is a measurement of the
time at which something happens and if
your timer has infinite accuracy then
the timer reports a real number and we
would have a continuous random variable
in the in this lecture sequence and in
the next few ones we will concentrate on
discrete random variables because they
are easier to handle and then later on
we will move to a discussion of
continuous random variables throughout
we want to keep noting this very
important distinction that I already
brought in the discussion of our
particular example but it needs to be
emphasized and reinforced that we make a
distinction between random variables
which are abstract objects their
functions on the sample space and they
are denoted by uppercase letters in
contrast we will use lowercase letters
to indicate numerical values of the
random variables so little X is always a
real number as opposed to the random
variable which is a function one point
that we made earlier is that for the
same probabilistic experiment we can
have several random variables associated
with that experiment and we can also
combine random variables to form new
random variables in general a function
of random variables has numerical values
that are determined by the numerical
values of the original random variables
and so ultimately they are determined by
the outcome of the experiment so a
function of random variables has a
numerical value which is completely
determined by the outcome of the
experiment and so a function of random
variables is also a random variable as
an example we could think of two random
variables x and y associated with the
same probabilistic experiment and then
define a random variable let's say X
plus y what does that mean X plus y is a
random variable that takes the value
little X plus little Y when the random
variable capital X takes the value
little X and capital y takes the value
little Y so X and y are random variables
X plus y is another random variable x
and y will take numerical values once
the outcome of the experiment has been
obtained and if the numerical values
that they take are lead
X and little Y then the random variable
X plus y we'll take the numerical value
little X plus little Y so we can now
move on and start doing some interesting
things about random variables
characterize them describe them give
some examples and introduce some new
concepts associated with them